starwars the last Jedi is finally about
to drop and like all Star Wars movies
it's focused on the continuing saga of
Luke Skywalker his sister Leia his
nephew kylo Ren and various other
characters who may or may not be
Skywalker's and/or Jedi but if you've
been under a space rock for the last
forty years and need a refresher on the
Star Wars saga we're here to serve
we start with Star Wars Episode one The
Phantom Menace long before the Galactic
Empire or the first order the biggest
baddie in Star Wars was Taxation yes the
primary conflict of the Phantom Menace
is a standoff between the Trade
Federation and the Galactic Senate over
trade routes and to think the biggest
complaint about these movies was that
they were too childish but we can skip
over all that as well as this famed trio
of offensive racial caricatures
because what's most important in this
movie is that we meet young Anakin
Skywalker future Darth Vader and current
immaculately conceived slave child Liam
Neeson esque Jedi Master qui-gon jinn
and his Padawan learner obi-wan Kenobi
are protecting Queen Padme Amidala of
Naboo when they land on Tatooine in need
of a new hyperdrive they're helped by
little Annie who instantly has the hots
for Padme qui-gon discovers the boys
body is full to overflowing with
midi-chlorians Witcher I think like Jedi
particles we need a midi-chlorian code
the reading is off the chart listen if
he thought the force was cooler when
it's a mystical power and not some kind
of pseudo science nonsense
congratulations you're everyone on the
planet except for George Lucas qui-gon
jinn is impressed with Anakin and his
sweet dopes hella good pod racing skills
and reports to the Jedi Council that he
may in fact be the chosen one you refer
to the prophecy of the one who will
bring balance to the force he insists on
Anakin being trained as a Jedi but the
council is against it no hunting the
good Jedi are the evil Sith namely
fan-favorite Darth Maul and his master
Darth Sidious who's definitely not Padme
friend Palpatine in a cloak and hood
Darth Sidious has been pulling the
strings to cause this entire conflict
which culminates in the Battle of Naboo
and the best darn lightsaber fight in
this whole
trilogy in the end Darth Maul kills
qui-gon jinn but then obi-wan kills
Darth Maul and George Lucas kills any
potential for bringing back the only
character from this movie anyone liked
and no Darth Maul's returned in the
Clone Wars animated series does not
count so save your comments obi-wan
promises to honor quaggans memory and
train Anakin Yoda reluctantly agrees
while realizing that the true problem is
that the Sith are back and while Darth
Maul is now dead that means his master
Darth Sidious is still somewhere out
there or maybe like five feet away from
it now we jump forward ten years in time
to start Star Wars Episode two attack of
the clones Queen Amidala is now senator
Amidala because Nobu's political system
is really confusing also confusing their
aging system because she looks exactly
the same
little anakin however has blossomed into
Hayden Christensen and he's already
brooding at a 10th grade level and he's
put in charge of protecting Padme but
really someone needs to protect her from
his extremely terrible flirting Anakin
dreams of his mother's in danger so he
returns to Tatooine where he and Padme
meet a young non-burning skeleton
version of aunt Beru and uncle Owen
hey that's cinemas joel edgerton
Anakin's mom has been kidnapped by same
people and tortured to death it's a
family film
so anakin goes nuts and slaughters the
entire village how very dark side of him
then he cries about it because he's
anakin meanwhile obi-wan spends a long
time investigating a clone army being
built on the planet Kamino all of whom
are the Jango Fett model or those the
2002 FETs oh very nice I've heard good
things with the untimely loss of darth
maul darth sidious is brought on a new
apprentice Count Dooku who is now
building a droid army to fight against
the Republic intergalactic dumb-dumb Jar
Jar Binks proposes giving Chancellor
Palpatine emergency powers to allow the
Republic to unless the clone army and
this is why you don't let Jar Jar do
anything obi-wan Anakin and Padme all
get captured by Dooku but the Jedi come
to the rescue via Deus Ex Shi Oda and
his army of clones obi-wan and Anakin go
after Dooku and they rave fight
Anakin loses an arm and is saved again
by Yoda while that CG does not hold up
Dooku escapes go to laments that the
clone wars have begun just like in the
title of this movie and on Naboo Anakin
and Padme marry in secret since having a
relationship is a big Jedi no no this
takes us to Star Wars Episode three
Revenge of the Sith where things take a
much darker turn for Anakin first
Palpatine is kidnapped and he rescues
him from Count Dooku by cutting Dooku's
head off it's a family film speaking of
family he also finds out that he knocked
up had made with future twins Luke and
Leia
hooray but he keeps having problematic
nightmares in which Padme dies in
childbirth
Palpatine who's still totally a
different person than Darth Sidious
takes advantage of Anakin's fear of
losing Padme telling him about Darth
Plagueis the wise and the power of the
dark side he could even keep the ones he
cared about from dying meanwhile in the
middle of the Clone Wars everyone is up
to their elbows and droids Yoda is
fighting with the Wookiees and obi-wan
is dealing with General Grievous and his
helicopter lightsabers back on course
son Palpatine reveals to Anakin that
he's actually and I hope you're ready
for this the Sith Lord Darth Sidious
only through me can you achieve a Power
greater than any Jedi Anakin reports
Palpatine the mace Windu who attacks and
disfigures him turning him into the
wrinkly old Emperor we all know and love
but then Anakin intervenes and mace
Windu is killed probably I mean he gets
lightning bolted very very far away we
don't see the body but it's not looking
great for mace Windu Anakin pledges his
loyalty to Palpatine who renames him
which is a really random made you just
kind of pull out of the ether but they
were locked into it so what are you
gonna do Palpatine orders Anakin to kill
everyone in the Jedi Temple and he now
goes all-in on the dark side and
straight up murders children it's a
family film meanwhile Palpatine sends
out order 66 to all the clone troops in
the Grand Army of the Republic
instructing them to kill their Jedi
commander
which is why in the new movies were down
to just one last Jedi it's sad really
Palpatine is now in full control of the
galaxy
Padme and obi-wan confront Anakin now
Darth Vader but he's too far gone the
Jedi turned against me don't you turn
against me
Anakin force chokes Padme then he and
obi-wan fight it's over Anakin
Darth Vader is left legless and horribly
burned and obi-wan just leaves him like
this
that's a real dark side move right there
Padme gives birth to twins Luke and Leia
then just straight-up dies Emperor
Palpatine grabs what's left of Darth
Vader and hasn't turned into the Vader
classic that we all know then Palpatine
lies and says that Vader killed Padme in
anger and he's upset
then they get right to work on an
exciting new construction project Luke
is sent to live with his uncle Owen and
aunt Beru Leia is sent to live about
senator Bail Organa is awesome space
convertible garage and Alderaan
Yoda exiles himself on Dagobah obi-wan
excises himself on Tatooine and George
Lucas exiles himself to go make Red
Tails now we jump forward 19 years to
rogue 1 a Star Wars story a team of
renegade steals the plan to the Death
Star and delivers them to the Rebel
Alliance who are battling the Empire
that's it that's all you need to know so
let's jump ahead to Star Wars Episode
four a new hope the Empire dominates the
galaxy except for a small plucky band of
Fighters the aforementioned rebellion
Leia now the Princess of Alderaan is a
high-ranking rebel leader her ship is
overtaken by Darth Vader
so she hides the secret Death Star
plants inside a droid named r2d2 who
escapes the ship along with his abusive
joyed coworker c-3po they crash land on
Tatooine and meet up with lonely orphan
Luke Skywalker who's currently working
his aunt and uncle's moisture farm
moisture farmer Leia got to be a
princess it just isn't fair Luke finds
r2d2 s message and r2 sets out to find
local kook old Ben Kenobi a name that's
only slightly more effective at hiding
an identity than just wearing a hood and
cloak oh wait he has that to Luke and
c-3po find artoo get attacked by sand
people which is a phrase I never want to
say again and are eventually discovered
by old Ben Wan Kenobi himself although
then he tells Luke that he and his
father were Jedi Knights together which
is technically true it was the best
stuff in the galaxy and that his dad was
killed by Darth Vader which is sort of a
poetic way to think about it but not
actually true and guaranteed to confuse
everyone for years
also obi-wan gives Lucas dad's old
lightsaber an elegant weapon
but um all civilized a obi-wan tries to
recruit Luke to help Leia but Luke turns
him down and heads back home to farm
some moisture only to find everything
destroyed and his aunt and uncle
murdered so Luke decides to leave a solo
moisture farming enterprise behind and
he and obi-wan meet up with the
smugglers han Solo and Chewbacca at a
local dive bar and arranged to take
their ship the Millennium Falcon to
deliver the Death Star plans to the
rebels Chewie here tells me you're
looking for passage to the Alderaan
system but before they can get there the
Death Star blows up Alderaan
[Music]
probably shouldn't have wasted so much
time listening to weird jazz which is
actually called jizz looking up the
Falcon gets sucked up by the Death Star
Luke rescues Leia but she's not
impressed and Vader kills obi-wan in a
pretty laissez faire lightsaber battle
compared to the prequel duels they meet
back up with the rebels and devise a
plan to blow up the Death Star by firing
a proton torpedo into its exhaust port
Luke uses the force lots of his friends
die in the battle
but he deals with it very well and it
works then everyone gets medals except
for chewing
[Music]
moving on to Star Wars Episode five the
Empire Strikes Back three years later
the rebels have a new base on the ice
world of Hoth but it's not long until
the Empire Strikes Back oh now I get it
Luke sees a vision of obi-wan telling
him to train with Jedi Master Yoda on
Dagobah he parts ways with Leia and Han
but not before his sister makes out with
him and we get to live with the distinct
possibility that Luke Skywalker's first
kiss was with his sister a bunch of
Imperial walkers and troops invade the
base and Han and Leia escape on the
Millennium Falcon pursued by the bounty
hunter Boba Fett Luke crash lands on
Dagobah only to be repeatedly negged by
a lippy green muppet who turns out to be
Master Yoda looking much less digital in
his old age
Yoda trains Luke to be a Jedi but before
he can finish his training he sees a
vision of his friends in trouble so Luke
cuts the rest of defense against the
dark side and goes to save han and Leia
the Falcon lands on Bespin and we meet
Hans old buddy Lando Calrissian who's
already sold them out to Darth Vader
Vader wants to freeze Luke in carbonite
and take him to the Emperor but he has
to test the machine on han first leaving
precious little time for flirting Luke
arise doesn't get frozen and then he and
Vader duel and then Darth Vader chops
off Luke's hand he was really using that
one Oh
also this Luke escapes by a deus ex air
shaft eeeh and is rescued by the rest of
the crew including Lando who everyone's
just forgiven already for some reason
and they escape in the Falcon Luke gets
a robot hand Lando and Chewie head off
to rescue Han from Boba Fett and Jabba
the Hutt on Tatooine may the force be
with you and everyone stares at the
galaxy
it is sad we continue on to Star Wars
Episode six Return of the Jedi Luke goes
to Tatooine and rescues Han from Jabba
the Hutt which takes up the first 40
minutes of the movie but there's a lot
more to get to so let's just move on
Luke returns today goodbye to find Yoda
dying before he goes Yoda confirms that
whole I am your father thing your father
then Obi Wan's ghost returns for a sit
down to reveal to Luke that he has a
sister Luke figures out that this must
be Leia
then Luke immediately
regrets again what was possibly his
first kiss before Luke even has a chance
to process all of this the rebels find
themselves having to deal with yet
another Death Star
this time protected by a fancy shield
the Empire has thought of everything
this time except that it turns out that
the shield has an off switch located on
the forest moon of Endor
Han Luke and Leia lead a team down there
and they join forces with the local eat
walks who declare c-3po their God Luke
turns himself over to the Empire and
tries to talk is dead and did not being
quite so evil
I feel the conflict within you let go of
your hate it doesn't work so they have
another lightsaber duel and Vader
threatens to turn Leia to the dark side
well this sets Luke off and he cuts off
Darth Vader's hand because that's how
they show love in the Skywalker family
the Emperor who at this point is openly
living his life as Palpatine in a hidden
cloak reveals that this was all a trap
meant to turn Luke to the dark side and
tries to tempt Luke to kill his father
and take his place as his new apprentice
Luke refuses and the emperor tries to
kill him with lightning but Vader
intervenes and throws the Emperor to his
death then Vader is revealed to be a
very pale very bald man he dies in his
son's arms it is sad meanwhile the
shield generator for the Death Star's
down and stop me if you've heard this
before the rebels blow up the Death Star
the score is now rebels to Death Star's
zero the rebels and Ewoks celebrate
their victory han and Leia make out and
Luke sees dead people the end except
it's not the end because we now have
star wars episode 7 the force awakens
it's now decades later Luke has gone
into exile Leia is a general and the new
rebellion the resistance and the first
order has taken the place of the Empire
literally almost nothing has changed
hotshot resistance pilot poe dameron has
traveled to jakku to pick up a map
supposedly leading to the location of
Luke Skywalker but before he can escape
Darth Vader's biggest fan kylo Ren shows
up freezes a blaster shot and captures
him Poe hides the map with dutiful
Sphero prototype bb-8 who escapes and
later winds up in the hands of Rey who's
been living on jakku killing time as she
waits for her absent family to return
are we finally going to find out who
they are we also meet fn-2187 AKA finn a
stormtrooper who's having second
about all the Stormtrooper he has to do
he fries PO but they crash land back on
jakku fin meet rey and bb-8 with the
first order in hot pursuit and they
escape in the Millennium Falcon which
Rey is already better at flying and
fixing than Han Solo everyone's fin
pretends to be part of the resistance
and rey agrees to help him get bb-8 back
to them and then look who it is
Chewie the Empire I mean first order is
in hot pursuit led by kylo Ren Hitler
wannabe general Hux and the mysterious
Lincoln Memorial asked hologram of the
Emperor of Supreme Leader Snoke the new
Jedi PS kylo Ren is actually han Solo
and Leia son which makes him Darth
Vader's grandson this galaxy is lousy
with Skywalker's speaking of Han Solo we
can skip over Hans debts to the cast of
the raid and the giant tentacle meatball
monsters he's smuggling because more
importantly we learn why Luke Skywalker
has disappeared he was training a new
generation of Jedi one boy apprentice
turned against him destroyed it all now
he's in hiding looking for the first
Jedi Temple han and friends go to maz
kanata's for cantina scene 2.0 and finn
comes clean to ray about being an ex
stormtrooper i'm not resistant I'm not a
hero
mash tries to give ray a lightsaber but
it gives her psychedelic visions which
have been the subject of much Internet
speculation Rey runs away and thin ends
up with the lightsaber right then the
first order uses their gigantic Death
Star star killer base to attack the
Republic many millions of people are
killed but we don't have time for that
because both the first order and the
resistance show up to get the luke map
and kylo ren takes Rey prisoner after
the battle han and Leia stiffly reunite
ginger here and Finn and Poe
passionately reunite kylo Ren tries to
force read Ray's mind to find Luke
except that she's able to resist him so
he throws a temper tantrum
and then Rhea uses her newfound Jedi
powers to trick a stormtrooper into
letting her go
oh did we forget to mention that Rey is
apparently a super powerful Jedi well
she is we get to the big finale the
resistance mounts an attack on
Starkiller base here's the plan
Finn han and chewie disable the shield's
while poe leads an attack on one
specific part that will blow up the
entire base it is a brilliant
combination of the plans from both a new
hope and return to the Jedi but then
kylo Ren shows up and Han tries to
convince him to come home spoiler alert
it doesn't work then kylo fights Finn
and Rey in the woods taking out Finn
until Rey uses the Force I don't care
what you have to say about training that
is awesome finally the resistance
figures out that you can't kill a big
base without a trench run and the death
star killer base is destroyed and
everyone escapes everyone reunites at
the resistance base and everyone gets a
hug except for chewing
then r2d2 wakes up for no reason with
the rest of the map to Luke that
everyone's been trying to find for the
whole movie this would have been useful
two hours ago artoo and we end with Rey
on an island thrusting a lightsaber at a
very beardy Luke Skywalker and that's
everything you need to know to watch the
last Jedi did we skip over anything if
we did you probably know it because
everyone has these movies memorized
anyway and you're just watching this
video for fun thanks for watching this
recap of Star Wars may the force be with
you